one of the things that I'm really
interested in is when you first started
your career maybe early in your career
could you have
um anticipated kind of being where you
are now and reaching the levels of
success that you've achieved uh and
where some of your goals like aligned
with that direction or did they look
kind of different when you were first
starting out
I
first of all they could not have it
um expected it
it's much more than I expected it's more
like it's one step at a time
in other words
you know you put one foot in front of
the other
and you keep doing that
and you climb
and then you get to a different level
and it doesn't seem
as much different
at that level
than
it would appear
from
others looking up at you at that level